what i hold in my hands right here is
the unemployment rate of different
industries in june of 2020 and the
reason why this is important is to look
at
which industries took the biggest hit
from coronavirus and i'm going to
explain to why this matters to you and
your sanity
and your future well-being but before i
do it let's talk about a couple
different things here together
number one we all know at this point 55
million americans lost their jobs to
coronavirus
number two reports just came back
yesterday that the u.s gdp
dropped 32.9 percent let me say this one
more time
u.s gdp in second quarter lost
32.9 that's like a company's revenue
dropping 33
which is scary but it's a country which
is even scarier
so now we know that data i'm gonna give
you the unemployment data of the
different industries here
but let's go a little bit deeper is it
fair to say
that in the future there's going to be
more pandemics that we know nothing
about
is it fair to say that in the future
there's going to be more viruses that we
know nothing about i mean if we've had
ebola mers sars
now coronavirus for you know all these
different kind of fluids that came up we
know nothing about it
is it fair to say that based on what cdc
and these experts keep telling us like
voucher that the average coron
average vaccine takes around 12 to 24
months of testing
until we feel comfortable to be able to
give it to people yes 12 to 24 months
which means what
the next time there's a pandemic the
next time there's a virus that we know
nothing about
there's going to be a president either
democratic republican
or third party that has to make a
decision whether to shut down or not
and no matter what party he is from if
he's republican
the republican party is going to say the
last president
shut it down and he got everybody to
wear masks social distancing and we got
people to not go to school kids didn't
go to school
and most people stayed home right if
it's a democratic president
the republicans are going to pressure to
say you better shut down because
president trump shut down china and
you're not doing your part right and
look how many people's lives and the
fear of not getting reelected that
person is gonna have to do what
same thing so this playbook is
officially here to stay
if you know what i'm talking about it
ain't going away right okay
let's say you and i agree on this if we
do the next time it happens again
do you want to have another fresh start
what do you mean pat let me explain to
what i mean by this
if you were in a certain industry you
took a big hit you're not to blame
because who the hell was under the
impression that we're gonna have a
pandemic and we're gonna be told to not
go to
kids cannot go to school and shut down
industries you and i didn't know that
we've never been through this before
this was the first time but if it
happens a second time around
and you stay in an industry that took
the mat took a massive hit
then it's your fault first timer not
your fault second time around
it is your fault so let's go through
some of these industries
the industry that took the biggest hit
okay
june over june last year unemployment
june of 2020
unemployment of june of 2019 leisure
and hospitality's unemployment rate is
is the highest in any industry i was in
vegas last week the place was
shut down it was people were there
walking around
but it wasn't the same i kept asking all
the employees we went to
mgm grand arena we're negotiating a
possible two-year contract
how was the situation what happened
we've had to let go of everybody
nobody's been working
it's scary people are leaving one of our
person that was there her boss
committed suicide literally last month
married commit suicide
because of the pressure of what's going
on and leisure and hospitality
29 unemployment by the way last year
same time the industry was only five
percent unemployment
then it's mining uh oil and gas
extraction is 17.8 percent then it's
transportation utilities 12.9 by the way
last year transportation utilities was
four point one percent
then it's in formation twelve percent
then it's total eleven point two percent
of these industries
then it's wholesale retail and trade
eleven point two percent last year was
four percent then it's construction
which is 10.1 percent
last year was 3.2 percent then it's
manufacturing 9.1 percent
then it's education and health health
services 8.6
then his personal business service is
8.6 percent then it's self-employed
unincorporated and unpaid family workers
8.1 percent
then government workers 7.3 percent then
agriculture
5.4 you know what the lowest one is 5.1
financial activities financial services
last year was 1.7
the lowest was financial services
financial activities
why why these industries why are some of
them taking big hits and not the other
ones okay
let me set this part aside so for you
you may be watching this saying well pat
man i'm in i'm in hospital management
i'm making six figures what do i do
you better start making some adjustments
because that business model ain't going
away these hospitals and these hotels
and
you know convention and all this other
stuff i'm doing business with them i'm
gonna be doing business with them for a
long time
but as a career you have to figure out a
way to position yourself for your
pandemic proof
by the way i'm not telling you
everybody's leaving that industry i
guarantee you most people don't like
change
most people like to stick to the same
thing most people don't want to even see
any kind of change
because as we get older as you get older
the hardest thing to do is change you
become this person that just kind of
wants everything
to be the same you don't want that but
that's also a scary place to be
but if you look at these stats and you
don't go study
how they took big kids why they took big
kids
and how long it's going to take for them
to recover and you keep staying in that
industry
and it happens to you again five ten
years from now you can be upset at the
government
you can't be upset at the economy you
can't be upset at a virus the only
person you can be upset about
is your decision i chose a certain
industry
i chose insurance and financial services
when i chose that industry
over other industries i was studying
health and nutrition
i was studying selling pharmaceutical
sales because i wanted to go work for a
pfizer company and sell pharmaceutical
sales i knew it was going to be sales
for me
i was studying mortgages i was studying
property and casualty i was studying
every single thing
to see what was good for me to go into i
chose specifically
insurance i used to be a stock broker
financial advisor i chose insurance for
a specific reason for me
i did not know that insurance could be
sold through
zoom i wasn't aware of that so i'm not
here bragging myself saying
you know i did a great job i made the
right decision i
chose the reasons of this industry for a
different reason
but then once i got in and the pandemic
took place we realized very quickly
95 of all our sales are not through zoom
it's not face to face
anymore it's all zoom so you got to ask
is your business model something that
can be accommodated
with zoom meaning if you're a pilot if
you're a
somebody in the travel industry can
somebody travel
telep you know teleport to a different
place it's not here yet so what's going
to be your solution what are you going
to be doing
you have to start thinking about that
because there's nothing worse
than being in an industry that keeps
taking a hit keeps taking a hit keeps
taking ahead
keeps taking a hit and you have to have
a fresh start oh my god everything's
going good
boom oh my god everything's going good
boom oh my god everything's good good
now you may watch this and pat i
disagree with you i think the next time
there's a pandemic
the world's not going to respond the
same way as we did this time i think
next time we have a
virus you america is not going to
respond to a discipline that's your
choice that's your risk
my play thinking like a general in the
military
is i sit there and i say the odds of
that happen and again is this
and the odds are being pressured to
respond to the way we were this time is
this
if that happens what's my next five
moves then i make my decision
but you'll have to make your own
decision as well so having said that if
you want to get deeper into this topic
i had to sit down with daniel de martino
which is a fed insider she used to work
for the federal reserve of dallas for
nine years
and she's a pretty well-known economist
everybody knows who she is in the
financial industry
we took this topic and we went very deep
into this topic and if you've not
watched that interview click here to
watch the interview
and if you have watched the interview
comment below
and let me know your thoughts about
today's video with different
industries and how could affect your
industry having said that have a great
week everybody take care bye
[Music]
you